the jurgen experience i was just
watching this
very disturbing commercial yeah um
yesterday with children and it was
talking about adhd and it showed a kid
that was not paying attention in class
and it showed these kids like playing
around and doing things they weren't
supposed to be doing yes and then they
introduced this medication and then you
have the child raising their hand and
then you have everyone clapping and you
have the child with a big smile on their
face and you've
medicated your child to be a successful
and integrated person in society should
i should i spit off about adhd yes
please that was my first book
on adhd it's the american
scattered or scattered minds depending
on which edition you got and that was
after i was diagnosed with it myself
in my 50s
um
what does it mean adhd yeah what is it
exactly is it real
oh it's real but what does it mean well
like if someone has adhd it's not like
you have herpes right like you say oh
i've got you got a disease well uh what
is it well they
that's the whole point
is that the medical profession
and a lot of the so-called experts think
about it as a disease
another one of these inherited diseases
in fact they say it's the most heritable
mental illness there is
and i say it's neither an illness nor is
it heritable
so the the hallmark are difficulty
paying attention when you're not
motivated yeah so kind of tuning out
like that kid in the commercial like me
okay poor impulse control so that you
tend to act out whatever emotion arises
and sometimes the hyperactivity
difficulty sitting still and then to
fidget and all that and that described
me to a t
and
but as soon as i learned about the
diagnosis
i knew something
this is not a disease and it's not
heritable despite the fact that
some of my kids were diagnosed with it
what is it so tuning out
is not a disease
so let me ask you a question if i may
okay
if i were to stress you right now um
create stress
emotional difficulty or attention for
you right now
what would be your options of dealing
with that of dealing with me what would
be your options i could get upset or i
could leave exactly you could fight back
flight or fight yeah
but what if you didn't have those
options
yeah then you're stuck
and now what does the brain do when
you're stuck like that gets distracted
it gets tunes out yeah tunes out you
want to do other things think about
other things in other words it's a
coping mechanism yeah it's normal i mean
the the idea that your
child who is uh you know an eight nine
year old ball of energy filled with
you know hormones and life and thoughts
and things they enjoy and then you make
them sit down
all day in this unnatural state in a
classroom with fluorescent lights and
stare at a teacher that's unmotivated
and underpaid and is teaching something
in a very boring and non-entertaining
way yeah and then if this kid doesn't
lock in like a zombie we need to
medicate them yeah well the other part
of it is
that
if you look at my infancy and it sounds
like yours
we spent our first year or two under
very difficult circumstances a lot of
stress infants can't help but absorb the
stress of their parents right they can't
help it what does an infant do could i
have escaped or fought back could you
have
all we could do is tune out yes but when
is this tuning out happening when our
brain is being developed right and our
brain
this is the part that nobody taught me
in medical school but it turns out that
brain science now teaches us that the
human brain develops under the impact of
the environment
so
the
the most
salient feature of the environment that
shapes the circuits of the human brain
is actually the relationship with the
parents
and if the parents are present and
emotionally attuned and available
child brains develop properly but the
parents are stressed
the child absorbs the stress
what can they do with it they tune out
and that tuning out then gets programmed
into the brain and then 10 years later
or 50 years later we say you got this
disease no you don't you've got a coping
mechanism
that's no longer working for you but it
had a function when it first came along
so this whole idea and and by the way
if a family comes to me with the adhd
child
i'll say to them
what you've got here is a very sensitive
child
that sensitive child is picking up on
all the vibes energies and stresses in
your family i want to help this child
deal with the whole family
look at the parental relationship
look at how
what stress is there in your life
look at how you react to the child
look at do you understand the child's
behavior
or the emotions that the child is having
or you're just trying to control the
child's behaviors look at all that and
very often parents will tell me after
they've read that book on adhd they've
totally changed their relationship to
their child the child changes what a
surprise
but you go to the most doctors
you got this disease here's the pill and
by the way i took those medications
and they helped me for a while you know
so i'm not when you're in your 50s yeah
yeah i'm not anti-male which ones did
you take
i took ritalin um which
i can tell you the story sure so
you know one of the hallmarks of adhd is
poor impulse control right so um
[Music]
i found out about adhd and even before i
was diagnosed
i took ritalin and
you know why'd you take it before you
were diagnosed
because i'm a doctor and i could hey and
oh so you diagnosed yourself well they
did and and so you at least assumed that
you had that yeah i knew i had it and
and but not only that also because i had
poor impulse control i never practiced
medicine that way
if you came to me for any problem my
first impulse would never be to write
your prescription
honestly it was obvious that you needed
it for an infection or something i'd sit
down with you and talk to you about
what's going on here
but but
not me
poor impulse regulation so i went to a
colleague of mine a medical colleague
i said hey bev i think i've got ahd can
you sum it can you give me some red line
so she writes me a prescription
then i took it in a higher than
recommended initial dose
uh because i mean if a little bit is
good then more must be even better and
again
it's not how i practice medicine right
but i came to myself that's a totally
different ballgame
so i felt immediately present and calm
and grounded and real yeah and it's a
stimulant and i went well it calms the
adhd brain then i go home and my wife
says you look stoned
because you're calm because yeah well
because i got this glassy-eyed
expression and
within a couple days the
ritalin made me very depressed that's
one of its potential side effects
so i did see a psychiatrist
i was formally diagnosed and they gave
me dexadrine
and i took that for a while that's an
amphetamine yeah it's amphetamine it's
another stimulant um
and it did help me i became a much more
efficient workaholic i could do even
it didn't change any of my emotional
issues but it made me more focused and
so on it helped me write my first book
but i i haven't taken them for decades
but
because also i know that
the brain can change if you treat it
right
so this the reliance on medications that
we have is is
a real poverty of the spirit the real
poverty of imagination a poverty of
medical education
the average doctor never learns this
stuff the average physician never gets a
single lecture on brain development how
the brain develops in interaction with
their environment so when you're seeing
and let alone do they hear about trauma
they don't hardly at all right
so when they see an adult with adhd or
depression or addiction
or or or bipolar conditions or
or for that matter autoimmune illness or
anything else
they don't think of trauma they just
think of this disease
and they think that the diagnosis
explains everything but the diagnosis
don't explain anything because think
about it let's say gabor or joe goes to
a doctor and
they diagnosed with adhd well
why is
what are the harmonics of adhd well
tuning out poor impulse regulation maybe
hyperactivity
why does gobber have poor impulse
control uh hyperactivity and uh tuning
out because he's got adhd how do we know
he's got adhd because he got poor
impulse control and tunes out and he's
hyperactive why is he hyperactive tunes
that have poor impulse control he's got
adhd how do we know he's got adhd
because you know
it doesn't it's circular it doesn't
explain it it doesn't explain anything
diagnosis describe things
and that there that can be helpful that
way but they don't explain
yeah one of the things that people get
they get
they get treated for and they get
diagnosed with is anxiety yeah and that
one drives me nuts yeah it drives me
nuts because people pretend that anxiety
is a disease yeah it's not and i'm like
my god the world should make you anxious
if you're a sensitive introspective
person if you're just looking at the
world itself and you you don't put it in
perspective like the world's it's filled
with anxiety the anxiety is
it's future problem solving you're
you're thinking about all the things
that can go wrong you're thinking about
your life in a you know potentially uh
devastating way and that's not a disease
that's just the way you look at the
world and people getting diagnosed with
it well
i won't quite agree with you on that one
in what way
i've felt anxious at times
sure the world is the same
if i actually the world is the same but
the way you look at it is not the same
right the whole point yeah that's what
i'm saying so the world is giving you
anxiety no the world is not giving me
anxiety right you're giving yourself
anxiety by looking at the world right
and by how i look at the world yeah
because i look into i can look at the
same world one day and feel grounded and
connected and i may
have all kinds of concerns about what's
happening in the world but my nervous
system won't be on edge my i don't know
when it's flowing i won't be anxious
that's my point is that it's not a
disease it isn't a disease right so
remember i talked about those brain
circuits of lust and care and rage and
and
and and seeking and so on one of the
brain circuits that we have as described
by a very
prominent late neuroscientist yak
banksap is for panic and grief
panic and grief are the normal responses
of the young human being or the young
animal
when care isn't available
so when the parents are stressed
distracted
economically or politically or because
of their own unresolved trauma
or whatever is going on in their lives
and they don't respond to the child's
distress they don't pick up the child
when they're crying
they make the child be alone when their
child is upset
the child's panic circuits get activated
as they should be because when the
child's panic circus get activated they
cry for help yeah that's so it's
necessary for survival a young animal
should feel panic when the adult
is unavailable
in a rational world in the same world
that child would be responded to but
when children as in our society are not
responded to
in their distress
the panic becomes built into their
nervous system and now you have a lot of
anxious people
and that's why more and more kids are
being diagnosed you're right it's not a
disease it's a response to the
environment and
the thought process of like leaving a
child alone when the child's crying is
that to toughen the kid up is the
thought process that
you don't want to encourage this sort of
behavior because then they'll do it all
the time
and then you'll develop an indulgent
child like what is the thought process
the thought process is that the child's
behavior is the problem
and so we have to fix the behavior by
controlling it now actually
the opposite is true
because
if you pick up the child when a child
has distress
physical or emotional distress
you're teaching a child that the world
is safe
and they don't have to be they don't
have to be anxious about it
and they can just ask for help
and
it doesn't entrench kind of crying
manipulative behavior
how how it works dr daniel seagal who's
a
psychiatrist at ucla and a very prolific
author and mind researcher
he says in his book the developing mind
that the child uses
the mature
circuits of the adult brain to regulate
its own immature unregulated circuits
so when the adults show up in a calm
loving way
that the child downloads that into his
own nervous system
and then he grows he doesn't it's not
going to be an infant forever at some
point he's going to be a mature adult
who knows how to take care of themselves
that's a natural process we don't have
to teach kids to be independent
independent is nature's agenda
because the parents are going to die at
some point the mother bear is going to
disappear that bear cub has to be able
to
look after themselves in a mature
confident way that's nature's natural
agenda what the mother what the mother
bear needs to do is to meet the the
needs of that infant bear so the infant
bank care matures so if we meet the
child's needs they're going to mature
out of that helpless state
with a sense of self-regulation and calm
confidence in their own capacity
when you don't pick kids up
what you teach them is that the world is
not available that they're alone and
that they're helpless
talk about a formula for anxiety